de la danse contemporaine à bercy pour
la première fois quatorze mille
personnes sont attendues ce soir et
surtout demain pour assister à l'un des
événements de l'année la 9e symphonie de
beethoven chorégraphe chorégraphié par
béjart et dansé par les étoiles de
l'opéra de paris antoine cormery et
fabien tormos au royaume du sport
spectacle il y a toujours eu des
artistes du mouvement des magiciens du
geste bref des chorégraphes admirable
mais des danseurs des vrais c'est la
première fois que bercy en accueille les
étoiles est pratiquement tout le corps
de ballet de l'opéra de paris
sur une immense scène circulaire devant
les 14000 spectateurs d'un palais
omnisports très loin de l'intimité du
palais garnier
je trouve ça bien que la danse eux
puissent aller dans d'autres lieux que
finalement les lieux habituels comme les
théâtres
je crois que la première sensation c'est
vrai qu'on a on sent justement qu'il ya
un passé avec un volume énorme et on
peut imaginer tout à fait l'écran
concerts ou les
des matches de boxe ou je ne sais quoi
alors c'est vrai qu'on a un vrai sens de
rentrer dans une arène
c'est en 1964 que maurice béjart s'est
attaqué à ce sommet de la musique qui
est la neuvième symphonie de beethoven
35 ans après quelques tours du monde
plus tard le spectacle revient donc à
paris sans retouche et toujours avec le
même message
lorsqu'on disait tous les hommes sont
frères 64 on se rend compte comme à 19
ça n'a pas tellement changé il faut le
redire il faut le redire il faut le
redire
parce que le sentiment de l'humanité au
sens grand du beau ont des gens le
comprennent qu'ils aient encore des tas
de gens il faut leur clouer sur la tête
de tous les hommes sont frères
c'est un manifeste antiraciste au delà
du discours politique l'hymne à la joie
de beethoven s'est transformé en hymne à
la danse et sur 360° bercy en est
l'écrin idéal